[音楽]
こんにちはカービィです私は
移動式
遊び場という活動を15年間やってきまし
た
この
移動式
遊び場というものは
車の中にいろんな
素材や
遊び道具この車自体も遊具に変身しどこで
も
遊び場に帰るという活動です
またそこにある
地域の資源や
子どもたちそして私たちのようなプレイは
かという人たちが
掛け算することによって
無限の
遊びができてきます
なんでこの活動したかということをお話し
たいと思います
私は
生まれ育ちが
新潟の
妙高というところでした
巻風呂で
生まれ育ってるんですが
学校
帰りには
川魚を手づかみで
掴んだり
森の中に秘密基地を作ったり
探検ごっこをしたりそんな幼少期を過ごし
てきました
ところが大学時代に
東京に来た時に
公園に行くと
木登り禁止
地を掘っちゃいけない
禁止事項にとってもショックを受けそこ
から活動スタートしました
子どもたちと
講演や広場で
多世代の遊びをしたりまた一軒の
長屋を借りて
子供基地というものを作り
放課後の
遊び場を作っていました
ところがその遊び場も2年後に取り壊しと
なり
次の物件を探してもなかなか見つからない
そこで
目の前に
シュート取った車が
車の中から
自動販売機にいろんなジュースや
ペットボトルを入れてるじゃないですか
これだ
この車を
改造し
車の中に
たくさんの遊び道具を積んで
街の中に
遊び場をすれば
子どもたちの遊び場が街で溢れそして
多世代がまた集うことができるんじゃない
かということを考えてやりました
もちろんお金がなかったのでいろんな企業
に
電話をしたり
企画書を作って
女性金を取って
スタートしました
今この移動式遊び場は
タワーマンションの
公開空知
広場や
団地の駐車場
商店街の
道路そして
仮設住宅や
避難所そういったところでも活動してい
ます
他にも
森の中や
限界集落そういったところでも
毎週遊び場を開催しています
さて
今日本の子供たちはどういった環境に置か
れているでしょうか
皆さん
子供の頃やった遊びをちょっと思い出して
くださいどんなことが楽しい思い出として
残っていますか
秘密基地
探検ごっこ
みんなでどこかに集い遊んだいろんな経験
をしてると思いますが
今
皆さんのいる街で
果たして
同じような環境が残っているでしょうか
子どもたちが同じように遊べてるでしょう
か
やはりなかなか今
この子供を取り巻く環境は複雑に絡み合い
難しい社会になってしまいました
その中で私はこの
移動式遊び場によって
再び子どもたちが
街の中で
遊び
建てないでつながりを作る
子どもと子どもがつながり
親と親がつながり
新旧住民が繋がるそういった活動ができ
ないかなと思ってやっています
さて日本の今子供たちの
幸福度幸せについてお話しします
ユニセフのスローガンでこんなものがあり
ました
子供たちが
幸せであるかどうかが
その社会が健全で政治がうまくいってる
からどうかの
証しであるということがあります
子供たち若者たちは
自殺率が年々増えてしまいました
コロナによって今400から500人の
子供たちが自分で命を絶っています
私たちは
子供たちが
幸せであるこういった
当たり前の環境を作っていくというのが
大人の責任からと思っています
そこでこの
移動式
遊び場によって一つ一つ
ご縁を丁寧に紡いでいこうと思っています
この移動式遊び場が面白いのはいつでも
どこでも変身するので
例えば
道路で遊びを展開してくると
近所のおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちが
フラッと寄って
懐かしいな
ベーゴマを教えてくれたりお手玉を教えて
くれたり
時には通りかかったサラリーマンたちが
学期でセッションしたりそういった
拠点ではできないいろんな多世代が
自然発生的に
交流するそんなことがたくさん生まれてき
ます
また一つ
被災地でのエピソードをお話したいと思い
ます
石巻で
震災から
6ヶ月経った時この移動式遊び場やってい
ました
4歳の
女の子が
お母さんと一緒に手をつないでやってき
ました
しかしその女の子は
ずっとずっとお母さんの手を離すことが
できずに1時間2時間そこで
遊んでいたんですが
ソーシャルワーカーの女の子がちょっと
近寄ってお話してみるとその女の子は
6ヶ月間
ご飯食べるときお風呂入るとき
寝るとき一切
手を離すことができなかったそうです
津波の怖さでお母さんからぎゅーっ離れる
のが怖いと言ってました
しかしそこの遊び場で
私は
衝撃的な景色見ました
お母さんの手を
プッと離したたたたたた
走ってコリントという
ビー玉を転がすゲームに夢中になって遊ん
でいたのです
お母さんは1時間
ずっと泣いていました
そこで私は
あ
遊びは
子供を
自由にし
世界を平和にする力がある
本気で思いましたそしてこの移動式遊び場
ということをやってきて本当に良かった
なぁと
改めて実感したシーンです
今皆さんの街の子供たちは
幸せでしょうか
いろんな環境の子どもたちがいますが
一人一人
幸せに感じていると思いますか
私は子供たちが
幸せいっぱいの社会を作りたい
本気でそう思っています
そのためには私は5つのまあ間と書くま
ですね5つの間を
意識して活動しています
1つ目が時間
子どもたちが
自分の時間を作れるかやらないといけない
ことがたくさんある中で
自分のしたいっていうことの時間を作る
2つ目
空間
子供たちの遊び場を街中作る
居場所をたくさん作る3つ目
仲間
加世田谷がつながり
赤ちゃんからおじいちゃんまでの仲間を
作れるかどうか
4つ目隙間あれしちゃいけないこれしちゃ
いけないの禁止事項がたくさんの
社会の中で
余白や
隙間そういったもので自分たちで考え自分
たちでルールを作るそういった社会を
作れるかどうかそして最後
手間
いろんなものを
手作りですしそこで
知恵や技術が伝承されていく
僕はこの時間
空間
仲間隙間手間の
ゴマをとても大事にして
活動しています
今私はこの
移動式遊び場を日本中に広げようという
活動をしています
2年前から
全国の
NPOや市民団体
企業や行政に
声をかけて
この移動式遊び場をたくさん
作りたいと思っています
目標は10年後に
100台の
移動式遊び場を作りたいなと思っています
各地域で
放課後や休みの時に
遊びがいっぱいあふれていくそんな社会を
作りたいと本気で思っています
子供にとって
遊びは
生きることです
生きる力になるんです
この
遊び溢れる社会を一緒に作りたいという人
は
ぜひ連絡ください
カービィと一緒に
遊びあふれる社会を一緒に作りましょう
でも
僕は
生きてる間の最終目標は
実は実はこの移動式
遊び場がなくなる社会を目指しています
この車がなくても
街中で再び
子どもたちが遊びあふれ
多世代で交流し
街中で笑い声がたくさん聞こえるそんな
日本を作りたいと思っています
そのためには一人ではできない
たくさんの皆さんの力が
必要です
ぜひ一緒に
遊びあふれる日本を作りましょう
またねー